the way that a mother loves a child is
unlike anything I'd ever experienced
before I have dogs and I thought well
it's pretty close it's not hello Bree
Larson welcome to Fandango frontrunner
thank you for having well it's our
pleasure there are a lot of young
actresses who wanted this role in room
what was your combination of emotions
when you found out that you got the part
I think it's a combination of excitement
and terror which is usually the right
combination I think anytime I feel like
I've really gotten to something
worthwhile it's when those two emotions
meet the situation in this movie is a
living nightmare a mother and son
confined to a 11 by 15 shed essentially
I don't mean to equate these two things
but my understanding is that as a young
girl you lived in a studio apartment
with your sister and your mother did you
access that at all when you were
thinking about MA I didn't really put
all of it together until right before we
started shooting but I realized that my
mom was going through a divorce at that
time and me and my little sister didn't
know and so we had moved from Sacramento
to Los Angeles and we didn't have a lot
of money it wasn't until much later in
my life where I started to remember you
know the moment that I was woken up by
her crying and kind of realizing that
that was not something I was supposed to
hear and I never spoke about it until
right before I shot room I went whoa
it's like some part of me knew that that
wasn't mine to to see or to talk about
but I knew from that experience that my
mom with very little resources created
this sense of imagination in this world
that was so big that I never knew that
we didn't have any money so because of
that I knew that I must have that inside
me as well and then everybody must have
the capacity to be able to make the most
out of a very hard situation and so room
became an opportunity to relive that
part of my childhood but from my
mother's perspective I want to watch one
of the really intense scenes from room
with a great it's gonna be okay we're
gonna get through this together okay
let's do it do you remember how Alice
wasn't always in Wonderland she fell
down down down
then a-hole well I wasn't always in room
I'm like Alice I was a little girl named
joy yeah and I lived in a house with my
mom and my dad you would call them
Grandma and Grandpa house house it was
in the world and there was a backyard
and we had hammock we would swing in the
hammock and we eat ice cream Keeney
house no Jack a real house not TV are
you even listening to me this whole
movie the the part in room is a study in
parental patience was that fascinating
to play that dichotomy and all of the
spectrum of patience in between yeah I
mean that's what I'm interested in in
general in the characters that I play is
contradiction in complexity because
we're not just one thing and being an
incredible parent doesn't mean that you
do everything perfect every single time
it was important to have these moments
where mahse patience was tested and
where in fact there are moments where
she seems like she's not a great mom
or she snaps at him when she shouldn't
but then what happens is she immediately
recognizes it and apologizes to him they
have such a strong connection that was
what I really was hoping to get at was
that in life we don't do everything
perfect were flawed human beings but
what takes real strength and beauty and
courage is to be able to acknowledge
that that was a mistake that happened
and rectify that all right well let's
see how the conversation continues when
I was a little older when I was 17 I was
walking home I you were still up in
heaven but there was a guy he pretended
that his dog was a guy old Nick we call
him old Nick I don't know what his real
name is but he pretended his dog was
listed on stage actor wasn't a dog he
was trying to trick me okay
there wasn't a dog all next to me and
why are different story no this is the
story that you get there's some moments
where no matter what happens ma can just
roll with it and then there's these few
moments where it's just almost too much
for her to bear has this experience
changed your outlook on becoming a
parent one day no it hasn't
but you worry that
that your darkness or your perception of
the world the the bad parts of yourself
er are gonna go on this kid and that you
can't protect them but in working with
Jacob I realized that kids are
incredibly resilient I felt like he was
made of rubber it's a push and pull
battle between parent and child your
capacity it just grows in this way that
I have never felt and it's painful hmm
it's a painful kind of love because it's
like this floating piece of you that's
outside that you can't fully control you
have to let it go and surrender it to
the powers that be and my mom had said
things to me like that all the time and
she would say you have no idea what it's
like what it feels like to be a mother
you won't know until you have a child
and Jacob became my first experience of
feeling the the just extreme depths of
that and and how much it hurts and how
necessary it is for life hmm is your mom
aware of the huge effect that her
strength has had now on this role and
your career oh of course I mean there's
been many moments that that the gifts
that she's given me have been extremely
helpful to me in my life even before
room but when I was doing the active
process of making this movie and I was
having this bizarre experience of trying
to create an imaginative world for a
little boy much like what my mom did for
me I would just have these moments where
I felt that it brought me to my knees
and I would call my mom I feel like I
probably called her a hundred times over
the course of this movie crying asking
for forgiveness it's a fascinating film
it's a riveting performance by you so I
say well done Embry thanks something I
couldn't have done without Jacob there
you go well that's clear well done if
you have not seen room be sure to check
it out you can buy your tickets on
Fandango and thank you so much to the
TCL Chinese Theatre IMAX for having us
here today and thank you for watching
Fandango frontrunner
you